each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay I think we're going to start now so
get comfortable so hopefully we'll have
an interesting panel session now
hopefully some very lively debate and we
had a great session last year on
software for science and kind of what
was wrong with scientific software
development and we could have gone on
all day so I'm hoping that this session
will be as vibrant and lively and so
it's pretty general so the title cloud
computing what do researchers want okay
so the structure of the session is like
this so we're talking about cloud
computing for research first thing I
want to think about so these are
questions that you have to answer okay
these are questions for the audience
okay why are using cloud so if you are
using cloud computing why using it and
what is it good for second question why
are you not using the cloud and what is
it not good for okay these are questions
again for you so you can think about
this whilst the speakers are giving
their talks and at the end the most
important point is what's missing what
could be done to make the cloud better
for your researcher k so think of this
as a gap analysis of cloud computing for
research okay so these are the three
questions that we will pose after our
four speakers okay who are have very
short talks I hope so we have four great
speakers here so we have Dennis Gannon
hot off a delayed aircraft from Seattle
who got here in the nick of time so I'm
very pleased to see Dennis here in the
flesh who is in Microsoft Research and
recently joined the Microsoft
connections team who's heading up our
cloud computing activity in microsoft
research connections so he'll be
followed by Marty Humphrey who has been
doing a science and more recently cloud
computing University of Virginia and
he's going to be talking about what
researchers using the cloud for Fortis
debt today
yep exactly by bright light exactly the
spotlight from your chicago marathon so
and then for Britta gagliardi who's in
research connections team in Europe will
talk about some of the experiences
through one of our large projects where
we actually have looked and spoken to
researchers about what they using for
cloud for and then Paul Watson from the
University of Newcastle will be talking
about some of the issues around cloud
computing and then we will get into an
open discussion so that's the structure
of the session so like to hand over to
Dennis all right I believe you can hear
me so they I was given this assignment
what does cloud for research mean and so
this is just very general you know so
what do we mean by the cloud and first
of all the cloud is a host for
computational services and data in its
most general form big companies like
Microsoft Amazon Google these clouds
that they've built are based on massive
data centers in the scientific community
there are other things called clouds
just about everything now is called a
cloud as you know but this is what we
mean we have a number of really big
centers scattered around the world in
you for our cloud that we use for
Windows Azure it's there's two of those
two sites big sites in the u.s. two big
sites in Europe and two big sites in
Asia and these are really big facilities
and they span a range of generations
from the early machines which we you
know were built by putting big racks of
equipment in place and wiring it all
together the way things used to be done
to the point now that we started working
with containerized servers and we pull
things together in big really self
sealed unit containers and now to our
next generation the fourth-generation
data centers where there's a blow-up of
an artist diagram of one of the next
generation centers we don't even bother
with a building anymore everything is in
a container it's spread out over a
massive
chunk of real estate and everything is
air-cooled you just have each one of
those containers contains about I guess
about 1500 servers all you have in each
container is three connections you have
the network connection you have a small
cooling connection and you have power
and that's all it takes to build a data
center you just assemble it that way now
on to what are the attributes of clouds
that make them interesting for science
well first of all the cloud is designed
and this is a distinction from what I
think it was a supercomputer it's
designed for 24 by 7 on-demand access to
services by thousands of concurrent
users hey that's fundamentally different
than what we see is a supercomputer
there are however some things that art
making these converge okay services run
in one or more virtual machines there's
on demand scaling and descaling so if
you create a service that talks to and
what do I mean by a service if you've
got a cell phone these days and I think
you all know this the general audience I
have to explain this but if you got a
cell phone you're probably using a lot
of cloud services already anything
that's interesting almost always runs on
the cloud and you your devices talk to a
service the service exploits all the
data it can be scaled out up or scaled
down as demand is needed you can gio
replicate your services compute and data
resources you have online access to
parallel and distributed data
collections it's not a supercomputer as
i said before but what we're starting to
see both with amazon and microsoft is
embedded HPC clusters for the
applications that really do need the HPC
MPI fast network connections and all of
these things are designed to support
massive scale data analysis computations
so what do I mean by research a cloud
for research is supporting communities
it almost fits on the slide
and building research marketplaces so
where I think the cloud will have its
biggest impact in science is when we
have large-scale data collections and
lots of users the exploiting services
and capabilities of a cook that a
community needs you a cloud would be
outfitted with advanced data analytics
and machine learning libraries curated
data collections data upload a curation
and visualization tools and strong
support for building science gateways if
those are familiar with that term that's
another name for a science service
sitting in the cloud as well as
tutorials now for example I think some
of the work being done with ipython it's
a picture of the ipython notebook now
running on our cloud Java C sharp F
sharp C++ these are all of the tools
that you need to build cloud services so
that's my context for what I see as the
cloud and my three slides are done so
next a gel Dennis identified anyone has
a burning question for Dennis or we
switch over to a burning question RT and
plenty of time for discussion off all
right not too controversial ending
one of the things that's not on the
slide is strong tool support for
proprietary languages proprietario like
for example Matt lamp in particular
that's right yes and I agree with that
just like everywhere else clouds and
supercomputers somebody's got to buy a
license I know you personally had to
deal with this challenge quite a bit as
well as some of the other proprietary
statistical packages if we anybody from
math works here wanna help us out on
this I think that's right the comment
was they haven't figured out the
business while I think they might be
close to it I don't know I hope so that
I agree that would be that would you
know we now have our for example jack
dongarra and his colleagues have now
have a little really nice company which
has are in the cloud that's really
exciting I saw a demo of that recently
very good and we've got everything
except for matlab well what about Ezra
insane but yeah yeah and matlab and all
the other commercial there's another
question back
just wondering when you're going to move
some of the cloud down into the southern
hemisphere ah good singapore's pretty
close but not that close I know I've
flown between those I know the data
moves a little faster than the airplane
but it's a very good question i would
love to see that actually now well
there's some some some things coming out
of at least for microsoft coming out of
the windows server group that enable us
to actually build out something on a on
a on a scale around the latest edition
of windows server which has support for
all of the azure capabilities but
building a big data center is what i'd
love to see in australia I'll talk to
talk to the CEO about that see if we can
get that fixed because I would love to
see it all right we'll come back to that
yeah yeah yeah we want lots of questions
for afterwards save them up okay over to
to Marty so I'm Marty Humphrey I'm a
last-minute replacement for Geoffrey Fox
if you like what i say i'm already home
free if you don't I'm Geoffrey Fox I'm
supposed to talk about why is the cloud
a good fit for research my goal is to
paint an overly rosy picture of the
cloud enough to make you object and
throw stuff and get into a nice
discussion at the end I apologize for
that last line I don't know how it got
up there so so why is the cloud a good
fit for research I'll state the obvious
which is arguably theoretical sometimes
in reality it's not quite this but just
remind everyone of the obvious we have
seemingly infinite data storage
researchers write that seemingly
infinite data processing everything's
fairly cheap and only getting cheaper
let's see no late-night calls to sis
admin's doing it within the enterprise
you
those and so will eliminate them
completely a lot of this is driven by
commercial entities and so you have the
best aspects of competition amongst
companies meaning they're going to do
everything to get your business and to
drive costs down and to innovate so
you're going to get more features it's
going to cost less it'll be more
reliable and you won't have to do a
thing Hadoop is a wonderful data
processing engine there's a large
community building around continuing to
build around Hadoop and so all this sort
of point paints a picture of we don't
have to build the infrastructure anymore
i mean that's that's been our goal
frankly for a long time researchers
would like to use the cloud because they
don't have to build their own
infrastructure they don't have to go on
that tangent right now so if we if we
take a step back whatever and ask how
our research is using the cloud there's
actually kind of two branches one is
this branch of its fine and there's
we're just going to use it the other the
other branch you go into sometimes is
it's broken we're going to fix it so
let's just look at each of those just
for a couple moments examples of how
it's fine how people are using the cloud
for research right now a very concrete
example is the the NSF call that went
out a couple years ago and was was
awarded last year and so this is kind of
fascinating to look at just for what
National Science Foundation picked as
projects to use the cloud and you sort
of look at each of them and it gives a
nice broad picture of the way the cloud
is being used for research right now
there's again I emphasize the broadness
of it there's a lot of different
dimensions of the different projects
there's security there's data processing
this is a really good fairly
comprehensive list small scale and
and it is subject to to an NSF panel but
there's a lot of different ways that
people are using the cloud right now
there's a lot of infrastructure that can
be used for a lot of different projects
and that's how people are using it right
now now if you if you go down the branch
of it's broken if you attempt to assess
how the community thinks it's broken one
way in which to do that the way I did
that was I looked at to the two of them
more favorite conferences and workshops
the hot cloud and the ACM symposium on
cloud computing which I guess takes
place next week these are the ways in
which people think that it's broken a
lot of those topics tend to be what
you've seen for a long time we have a
decent emphasis and decent experience
looking at some of these data centers
arguably provided a different context
but a lot of these problems we have some
idea of what they are and how to tackle
them so to put them both together why is
the cloud a good fit for research you
look at both branches no matter what
can't get flan to there's arguably a
compelling plan going forward the it's
fine path if you choose to believe that
the cloud is fine and there's good
reasons for you two to go down that path
similarly if it's broken if you believe
that it's broken right now there's a lot
of people working on it it's only going
to get better and so if you no matter
what side you you're looking at arguably
the cloud is a good fit for what you're
trying to do now hopefully I said
something objectionable but we can
discuss that afterwards I guess Thank
You aunty has anyone got any questions
for Marty just follow these up here on
his own otherwise will hand over to a
brit see ok
okay very good by the way I didn't run
the marathon but I was stacked five
hours on the airport coming here so i
think is you know it's longer than three
hour and forty so um again I i don't
think that previous speaker has been as
controversial as kenji are was open and
again my a short communication will not
be that controversial either I just
pinched from Danny's gone on standard
cloud deck for science the long day but
that was covered by the keynote speakers
this morning by drupal's so definitely
what I think I i found interesting is
the confirmation and more and more you
can do science as more group of people
in a remote location and those people
tradition didn't have access to big
computer resources and probably the best
day yet was their laptop or maybe a some
departmental cluster so I think you know
this is what people now understand more
and more you have the top of the of the
scale and the people like my former
colleagues at CERN in energy physics
that I know to you you know design and
build the complicated computer system
the grid was a very popular model there
still is and what the demonstrator that
could discover the EEGs with a very
large worldwide you know more than you
know lost the count you know more than
200,000 processor scatter around entire
the entire globe so that is going to
stay there thing for certain for certain
communities and we have you know the
closely embedded computational
scientists working in a computer center
good example as very familiar with this
Barcelona supercomputer center where you
have you know earth scientists chemistry
many other really work in the same
building because those people you know
they do need the high response time they
do run programs that need NP I libraries
they do
need fine-grained parabola knees but
everybody else as we said I mean you
know can really do with you know
commodity computing that is now
delivered over the network and that
basically what the previous speaker were
speaking so I want just to give another
more funding agency angle and that is
gain is nothing contravention I'm
stating stating the obvious because i
heard that discuss in many many meetings
public funding agency or National
Science Foundation department of energy
in your States the European Union which
are more familiar in Europe they found
at the level of billions research and
all research project they found there is
a you know more or less a good fraction
of the ground there goes to provide
computational resources for the project
so in certain cases that can use a
computer center or water you know
already established computing
infrastructure but often they go out and
the easiest solution is to buy a cluster
run the leaners windows whatever and
that is normally run managed by a bunch
of PhD student and two three four years
later the project is over the PhD
student you know hopefully go and do
something more useful more interesting
and well the hardware basically get
decommissioned and that's not too bad i
mean after all you know old people like
me to get your salary pay from IT
industry what is good that people buy
ardoin that's right away it's good for
the business but what I'm worried is
what happened about the data now not all
the data produced by NSF and european
union support approach are useful but a
large fraction of those are and we know
they're more and more the funding agency
required the data to be widely available
if the data produced with public funded
money then this should be made available
to the entire scientific community and
that's not easy if at the end of the
project everybody goes so the best what
people do it just to archive the data
somewhere on some
world media and that's probably the end
of the story because you know 23 years
later if you want access to the data no
way so the only way to preserve the data
is to make them available over the
internet and that basically means that
you know with an entire virtualized data
storage that you can do more easily so
is nothing that you could not do before
without a conventional approaches but i
think you know really the virtualization
that we reached today allow we know we
cloud-based computing solution for
funding agency basically to virtualize
one step for one step more so really
visualize the ground that goes to
support computer resources and if you
make a simple calculation out of the be
you know the European Union spend
basically 1 billion euros around per
year to support research so even if only
ten percent goes to you know invest in a
cluster let's say volatile ardh where r
is under a million so with under minions
you can provide and procure a lot of
data storage of the cloud and a lot of
computer service so I think you know my
assumption for discussion here today is
that you know by using cloud computing
the way the previous speaker I presented
we are leading to more science fair tax
payer euro or dollar or whatever so but
its cloud good for any kind of science
well you know I don't believe so I mean
as we said there are you know the top of
the or the pyramids or the curve still
require are the solution and in in
Europe to try to assess what the cloud
is good for and not only that but our
cloud-based solution could integrate
with supercomputers we cluster etc we
started two years ago with the strong
support and an investment also by a
microsoft research in microsoft
corporation that provided basically a
considerable amount in a true denny's
and
and his group a consumer amount of Asia
resources we started and we round this
venue see project and you can get more
information on the web we completed a
couple of months ago with a pretty a
pretty good performance and there are we
we built about you know 27 different
user community and at the end we
basically asked the each of the user
community to assess your experience you
know moving application to the cloud or
developing from scratch and we use those
parameters performance error management
scalability you know scalability is what
you know Dennis was explained before
completeness interpretability the
learning curve of you know working is
this kind of knew our computer
infrastructure convenience or business
and the result in a nutshell I don't
want to take too much too much time the
result are basically this one so you see
that the scale is 125 so five mins is
very good and one means is very bad so
you see that you know out of this 27
user community we got a private II
pretty good score so more than eighty
percent they score between four and five
now it is a little bit of course bias
because the people that have been
feeling the questionnaire people that
they really wanted hard to sperience the
clouds I think the idea the the moods in
which they enter the project was a very
positive one but even taking that into
account I think that is a pretty good
result that really alike to to share
with you and discuss and that's
basically it okay thank you for brit's
yeah so just switch over to pull any
questions for for its here just while
we're switching over oh okay since
fabrizio used one of my slides it
contained an error then I want to
correct if case anybody from the NSF is
here the NSF does not require all data
to be made public NSF requires that
everybody have a plan and they don't
right so those of you that were
panicking because you have NSF funds hey
and you work your plan did not say make
it public you're not in trouble yeah on
the other end it is fully true for
European Union so if you get european
union money be prepared to make your
data available so yeah in the UK that's
that was mandated last year I think that
all publicly funded research you had to
make your data publicly available and
that's a requirement and the penalty for
that is you won't be eligible for
funding so it's a big stick are so so so
in the UK the requirement was I was one
of the people on the working group was
within a year of a debt piece of data
being produced it must be catalogued on
a web accessible site so that anybody
can find out about the data okay see so
within a year of the data being produced
it has to be in a publicly accessible
catalogue at the bottom of it it could
say email the university so they can
recover the USB hard drive that it's on
just fine but so it has to be available
say and there was a big discussion about
privileged use of data for publication
because they were trying to protect
obviously the researchers first use
privilege of their data whilst also
complying with a sort of nation wide
open access type policy sis pretty
interested it's worth having a look at
the the UK rcuk data policy because it
is pretty interesting so and Paul is in
fact from the UK Sarah Newcastle sick so
we can discuss that in a bit more say
over to pull Watson yeah okay thanks so
we've heard a number of examples of why
clouds are a good thing and personally I
think that clouds have the potential to
really revolutionize science this
fantastic ability to give people the
resources that they need as in when they
they need them as a potential I think to
really democratize science and short and
time scales and cause a step change in
many different areas but what I want to
talk about is why then if this is the
case why on clouds
use more often why is it only a small
proportion of research that can actually
exploit cloud computing so the last five
years have been working in a group
that's collaborated with scientists
across a whole range of areas from x-ray
spectroscopy through biology through
chemistry to archaeology and so we've
got experience of trying to work with a
wide variety of different sorts of
researchers both in academia and
Industry and based on that I want to
talk about what I see has been the three
barriers which are currently preventing
cloud computing from being more widely
used and I want to I want to talk about
these not because I want to be the doom
and gloom merchant in this group of
speakers but because i think that
community like this could actually
address these issues over time and so
open up the benefits of clouds too much
wider audience so I'll go through the
three barriers now so the first one is
building cloud applications so one of
the great things about clouds is that
you can get resources that you need when
you need them unfortunately there's two
things that you need to do if you are to
exploit cloud so one is to get the
resources you need but the other one is
to write the software which exploits
those resources and at the moment in the
main it's something like this a few
heroic individuals or groups are work
with very low-level cloud infrastructure
and building these siloed applications
from the ground up and I think one of
the sad things almost a catch-22 for
cloud is that if you look at those
researchers who could benefit from cloud
computing the majority of them can't
benefit because I love it get access to
the IT resources they can't actually
write the sorts of applications that
they that they need and an analogy I'd
make it's a bit like taking a researcher
into your machine room in your
University researcher who knows they
could cause a step change in there in
the particular research if they get
access to I to resources if
it builds new sorts of applications to
analyze their data generate new results
they spit like taking those researches
into your machine room and putting them
at all the servants in there you go all
your problems are solved we'll give you
access to this and you can do whatever
you want on them and I think things are
are made worse in science because I
think in general if you distill what
scientists want to do then they don't
just want to really knock up some simple
application in the main looking for
applications that are scalable they need
to deal with huge amounts of data large
numbers of processes if they need to
paralyze what they are what they're
doing potentially large numbers of users
if they're really to have an impact and
then it needs to be reliable it's no
good if they build systems which keep
falling over if the users become
dissatisfied they'll move away from
these cloud services and finally
security in many areas is really
important be a medical researcher
perhaps even in in companies where
they've got business critical there and
as we all know finding people who can
build scalable reliable secure services
well it's a very hard challenge to find
those people so this is my barrier
number one the building cloud
applications actually hard at the moment
because we're building from a little bit
so the challenge I would make to the to
the community would be how do we
actually raised the bar how do we
produce cloud middleware which makes it
easier for researchers to exploit the
potential of clouds this brings us
neatly to barrier number two which is
security so if you talk to somebody in
an IT department typical person in IT
department and so you're thinking about
using cloud computing then they might
well say I wouldn't do that not secure
you should use our own internal
resources and I've heard it said by a
Salesman he was trying to sell cloud
into a in organizations that you never
got the IT department he said some
allure to the IT departments like
getting turkeys to vote for Christmas
he said they'll just never agree to it
you should go to the finance director
and sell it to the finance director but
there are real challenges it's not just
a story put about by three departments
that there aren't issues so this is a
typical workflow that we have been
involved with in one of our one of our
projects and it's with some medics and
you've got some data which is a mixture
of patient data and some accelerometry
about their activity and then the
pipeline effectively strips out the the
patient did it just leave me with the
accelerometry data and then you do the
core analysis and that's the thing which
takes all of the the effort that's Wade
really like a cloudy would scale out
that sort of analysis and it produces
the results that they produces the
results at the at the end and so how do
you decide where you can where you can
run that can we run this on a cloud or
not this patient therefore for some of
it and this is exactly the sort of issue
that people trying to build cloud
applications come across when you talk
to say medics with medical data what
what we try to do is we have this we
have this system which we created to
address the first problem which was a to
produce ER some middleware for science
that runs on clouds and we can run this
internally on a private cloud as you
call it so you give us some servers and
we put this up or you can run it on a
public cloud like as you now that means
that when we have these discussions we
can say depend on what the medics thing
and what ethics forms are filled in ok
we might go down the the the left-hand
branch because we don't take any of this
data out to a public cloud but then of
course you lose all the benefits of
scalability and so on that you get from
cloud so then the issue is well could we
split this pipeline up for example and
run some of it internally and some of
the external and that's an utter that's
a possibility but even then what you
find is that sometimes you're not making
these decisions based on technical
values but you make them on social
technical issues people just feel that
their own servers inside their
organizations are much more secure than
those external service that are out
in the in the public cloud and so this
isn't a problem that we can solve with
technology so Leo I'm sure there are
technological solutions tools and
techniques that we can use to try and
increase the range of applications that
people are comfortable with moving out
or cloud we also need to deal with that
trust issue as well so I think the
question here is how can we build up
trust in clouds partly through
technology but partly through arguments
about the relative benefits of private
service within organizations and public
servers in the cloud the final barrier
which is one that we've seen more in the
last year or so but we didn't really
hear much about two or three years ago
this is to do with with governance so
the issue here is that this is a
traditional organization that we might
have seen about five years ago where if
you wanted to do anything with a
computer then you went and talked to
your internal IT department and there
are these stories are maybe sure whether
apocryphal but now about people who go
to their IT department say I need to
create a new service I've been given
some day to analyze my boss says it
needs to be done very quickly and the IT
department says oh okay well we can meet
you and discuss it two weeks on tuesday
and so what happens is that the the hero
of this story then just goes out and
grabs cloud resources analyze the data
gets the results back and his boss is
delighted the hero gets promoted the
boss is able to release a new product
out in the market more quickly and the
company makes makes money from it now
the part of the story that nobody ever
ever tells which is because I just
invented it yesterday but this is
something which suggests that this is
this is something which we're hearing
more and more about is what happens next
is that the company a year later has an
fda audit and the order has come in and
ask to see the data that it's been used
in producing this pharmaceutical product
and so the boss goes to the the
hero and says where is it and the hero
says well I you know I put on my credit
card I'm obviously once we got the
results I've stopped paying for it now
there's no way we can get and so the the
end of the story is that they the
company gets find a large amount of
money and our hero gets sucked in the
end because he hasn't managed to retain
the day according to the rules that the
company's supposed to obey and this is a
problem that didn't used to happen
because the the boring slow internal IT
department when you went to them they
used to negotiate the SLA with you that
I've sensible questions about well how
long does this do i need to survive how
much does it need to be how available
does it need to be who's going to pay to
to keep it up there for the for the
length of time that we need to we need
to keep it and this is going because of
people going directly out to clouds and
this is an interesting barry i think
because the berry is not one that's
caused by the cloud it's not a barrier
that's caused by the researcher this is
a barrier that's been now put in place
by people high up in organizations who
are starting to worry for example we
just heard about date retention Research
Council's it's those sorts of issues
which are causing heads of universities
and heads of labs to worry about these
these sorts of issues so unless we
address these sorts of issues then the
problem will be that more and more
they'll be restrictions on the use of
cloud so the question is I think how do
we get the benefits of cloud while still
keeping the right sort of governance
that organizations need so those are the
three barriers that I wanted to that I
wanted to razor I think that you can see
two two futures so one future would be
that we keep going as we are at the
moment and so clouds are only exploited
by a small proportion of researchers or
the other future is one where we try to
address barriers such of these and then
we dramatically increase the proportion
researchers you can benefit from from
the cloud okay thank you
with anyone got any questions for Paul
just well these up here I haven't when I
doublet microphones thank you for a very
clear presentation if I understood
correctly then two of the barriers are
caused by internal IT departments I
think it goes deeper than that actually
so I think that there's a it's easy to
say these are caused by just the fact
that IT departments are just fully daddy
stuck in the mud don't want to move
forward into the brave new world of
clouds but actually that's a that's a
real issue how do you retain governance
and in the case of security is a real
issue about medical d'etre or business
confidential data going out into the
cloud so I think although I presented it
initially through through the eyes of
the IT department I think these are real
issues that we do need to address no I
can imagine and I heard their stories
from researchers myself so they would
like to know how do you see the role of
the IT department in a cloud um well I
think that if you look at all of these
issues so the the issues about
governance if you look at the issues
about security if you look at how to
build these systems these are rules that
the IT department could take on so if
they could move up the stack from
managing hardware and start to support
users to get the most out of clouds and
deal with these issues then there's a
future for IT departments whether
they'll do that or not I don't know I
actually think that this is starting to
happen you see this within the
universities at the private sector it's
going on all the time now the IT
department is negotiating with the cloud
vendors the number of companies that are
operating in the cloud I mean seriously
operating on very large scale do it
through the negotiation of the SLA with
the cloud vendor the IT department is
deeply involved in the case of the
university's we've had discussions with
many university CIOs
about how to integrate the commercial
cloud in to their organization as
largely for the data scalability and
analytics capabilities to complement
their super computing capabilities so I
think that's starting to happen I think
that's where it has to happen is through
the IT department yes thanks for this
I'm wondering about data portability
from the cloud damn thing that's a big
issue that if you stuck with one cloud
provider where it's Microsoft Google or
any other that you're stuck with them
for the rest of your life because there
is no data portability standard or
whatsoever currently being conceived so
I'm thinking how could we as a community
say somehow force them or work together
with the club of virus to to get
something on this data portability going
on and any opinion on that maybe I have
I always have opinions actually there's
a number number of things that are
happening on this regard there there's a
research data Alliance which is a new
group European us managed group of
researchers that are taking a look at a
lot of issues not directly the
portability issue but in terms of the
common standards about data models they
just have their first meeting a week ago
and that will be a large effort you also
have you know this is the the lock-in
argument I've heard many times I've got
by data here and I'll never up trapped
there for life oh my god I'm stuck well
that happens wherever your data is
whether it's in commercial cloud or in
you know I used to have big stacks of
tapes and I don't have them anymore but
yeah that's really locked in that day
anybody else want to talk about lock yet
yeah we we have been struggling
discussing with that in in also in the
contest of the funding agency in europe
with european union and in fact as part
of the divinity project mentioned before
we did try to offer our end user an
extra layer where there could be some
how easily the front from the
infrastructure but it also depend very
much how the volume of the data because
you know if you know so clearly energy
physics that produce you know 15
petabyte of data per year there is very
serious because you know whenever you
know and whatever you do it's very
difficult to retry those data that's why
i think we should always go back to the
idea of the long tail so for relatively
small group of scientists who cannot
really use our performers can be
resources we don't under gigantea amount
of data but they did i'm much more
modest in there i mean you know the data
looking as much as much less of an issue
but you know for big producer of data
like energy physics that is a big issue
they just so the question the question
was about the long tail and the fact
that many scientists with less data is
still a huge problem sir Denis right
right oh I agree one advantage what
advantage of the of the fact you've got
emitting scientists with smaller amounts
of data is you could actually move data
much better that way you have more
concurrency in the data streams and so
you get higher bandwidth but I also
wanted to mention I Fred mentions before
there's organizations like the dataverse
organization out of from Harvard who
have been building out infrastructure
for for collecting and cataloguing data
across multiple repositories you also
have dura cloud from MIT which is
another very interesting one and so
these are these are infrastructures for
data and data cataloging and curation
that span multiple multiple institutions
you can do automatic replication between
things and this helps I mean I'm
interested in all this is a really
important question society yeah I have
two questions one is for Dennis
specifically for could you brief fasting
lipid on the HPC and the auto scanning
of azure and a lot of question i have is
probably one is about cloud computing
and big data we know that we have data
ranges from megabytes or gigabytes
pearpads two terabytes what's the pros
and cons so by creating those big data
to the cloud platform either commercial
or your own private or community ok so
the comment the first question was about
auto scaling and HP support oh that's
you okay so HBC support on Azure I
invite you to come to the it is coming
and the details will be available along
at the supercomputing conference in Salt
Lake City and I don't know if how much
has been made it's been made public that
it's coming I so you should talk to the
Amazon people who actually have this all
now commercially available
in terms of auto scaling that happens
there's a standard API for doing that
and you can plug into that API to
instantiate new virtual machines now on
the the other one was about the data
issue how to move it yeah well this is
actually so it's very interesting with a
big data moving big data this is
happening already from the commercial
customers the key to moving big data is
having many parallel streams of
concurrent data and it's going on
already but I could go into details with
you about that later okay follow on girl
I think follows on from these things I
think I'm two points firstly I think
data portability isn't very important
for adoption I'm involved with a cloud
environmental cloud service which we're
developing because a lot of people don't
want to go to because they think you're
locked in and it'll be cheap at the
beginning price will keep going up of
course you're locked into one supplier
and they don't want to go to that route
because you can't predict their future
costs even if it maybe they think it'll
be more efficient it also sounds like a
car salesman in saying it and then the
other point thats related to this I
think there's a fourth barrier I
completely agree with all the three
barriers that we've come up certainly
what we're doing we come across this
logically the governance issues the
fourth one is a lack of it educated
scientific customers or whatever hood
that people a lot of scientists now
don't get very good computing skills in
their first degrees or even their PhDs
they get specific things will say not
sitting in advanced computing
environment so they can't be the
computing hero because they don't know
enough to do it it's and it may not be
the unknown unknowns but it is for many
of the scientists and zone just one
thing on this cost for data storage
actually the trend over the last few
years has been to continue to see it
drop and so it might be going up someday
also I could talk about spying a car
later I've got the car for sale
well I just wanted to make the general
point that one of the good things about
clouds is that you move your day up
there and then you do your processing up
there so if we're worrying about data
portability people need to worry about
moving your applications around as well
Nigel award from nectar we're building a
research cloud in Australia a public
research cloud mystery are about 4,000
cause at the moment growing to 30,000 by
the end of next year just wanted to
comment on two reasons we think
researchers like the cloud one actually
is the lack of a service level agreement
we think it allows researchers to
innovate they can spin up a couple of
virtual machines try something out if
it's successful it can scale so then
they haven't had to invest in their own
infrastructure so while I agree it's a
barrier we're moving into an operational
phase it's actually an advantage it lets
it lets scientists innovate as well and
something else we're starting to see is
the sharing of virtual machine images as
a way of sharing science and
repeatability of science it's not as yet
just about making a code open source
it's creating a virtual machine image
and allowing others to download that and
install and use that as well so just a
couple of new advantages so I noticed
that nobody listed standards as an
inhibitor and it seems like though the
grid standards apply a good bit that the
cloud community hasn't come kind of to
participate in the grid standard so I
was wondering if you know whoever on the
panel wants to address that yeah thank
thank you for giving me the pleasure to
responded sure what standards you know
that they are definitely something that
cloud should look into that I think they
didn't come up that strongly as we so
you know what we have been discussing
standard in the context of grid
computing for the last 10 years but I
think in a grid really originated and
more in the Indus aunty finger nakid
makes environment so clearly the
interoperability was a much more felt
important issue cloud they've been
essentially originated in the commercial
world where you know interoperability is
not that strong now there are there are
attempt I know about in Europe there are
attempt in Europe to discuss and decide
when and how is there is the right time
to introduce thunders because in a
Doozer of dilemma if you know I
introduced them too early you might
actually distort and you know kill at
the the innovation and if you wait too
late what that is too late I mean you
know as the verge so we have and again
encouraging people to attend events we
have been running event you know when I
say we the the cloud community in Europe
web be running in a van cool cloths k
for the last four years we're going to
have another another of this event in
February in Brussels we're in an
industry standard organization like nice
from united states and similar
organization for europe are going to get
together really to discuss and address
this issue so yeah something that we
should look into so I'm feeling perhaps
also something about grid standards and
cloud standard Sarah yeah right so I
think that I think the difference is
this that what greater about was about
different organizations who had their
own management regimes sharing resources
and for that to work what you needed was
standards to do the basic thing so you
need a security standards of people
could authenticate themselves against
different organizations systems you
needed standard ways to transfer data
between different organizations you
needed standard ways to kick off
execution between different
organizations so it's absolutely
necessary in the grid for four people
have some sort of an agreement on on how
to communicate between organizations the
cloud world is different because what's
happening is that in general people are
just grabbing low-level resources from a
cloud and building whatever software
they want just in one lump
on one cloud and therefore it's under
just a single management regime which
they're create and so I think that's the
difference which is why the grid world
had a focus on standards in the cloud
world hasn't until now one final comment
on the standards is that there actually
is a lot of standard work that's going
on it is not the same level as what was
happening in the grid world and as you
know i know that world pretty well
myself but for example in areas such as
government compliance with standards in
europe and data sort of the data
locality issues that happen in europe
and that Europe is working on standards
there that the grid providers have to
work with we have things like HIPAA
compliance a lot of different compliance
issues security issues authentication
issues these are things that are
actually happening and and to the extent
that you know Microsoft has decided that
we will support linux is something of a
interesting thing for us and sort of fun
and that's now pretty much a standard
capability on every cloud so so there
it's happening but it's happening driven
largely by government and by big
commercial customers ok hello my name is
chris from the maiden I'm the CIO of the
veterinarian Faculty of the duties
Maximilian's university in eunuch so I'm
one of those IT guys you've been picking
on here and I'm not convinced in
cooperating with the cloud for my
faculty and I can tell you the reason
why it is what I see is that we are
running for both for the same kind of
money there are 100 millions I hurt on
in the EU and I would like to have that
too and I could do very very good things
with that and so so there has to be a
reason why the clouds should take that
part of the money and why the cloud
could do these those things better than
I can do that I I am convinced that you
can do that better than I can but
there's one thing that I'm missing here
in the discussion and that is privacy
and freedom of research we see in all
those parts where cloud computing is
starting to live like facebook google
mail etc all these things that profiles
are made up from the use of those
systems and what what is your opinion on
privacy what is your opinion on profiles
of the researchers what are you going to
do with that are their policies on that
can we rely on those and that are the
questions why I say hmm I don't know if
they are the right partners using free
services so in some of those you're
actually talking about free services
like Gmail and some of those which
you're getting something for free so you
have to also make sure you differentiate
between the two yeah I think that's a
very good point are those competent you
know businesses that are essentially
they are buying information about you
and that's that's why they give it you
you think you're getting it for free
you're actually selling your identity to
them and you're not getting paid very
well help by the way yes okay I agree on
that that there is a difference between
a commercial system and and a free
system but there still is the the
possibility of of doing something else
with the data of what we are doing there
and that is that is something which is I
think a part of human being that you are
concerned about that and I didn't hear
any information here on what is going to
happen with these possibilities there's
a difference between I think the
customer for a cloud provider the
customer is is usually a business and
that business then has access you know
it's you know it sets its own policies
and rules and agreements with its
customers the cloud provider for example
Microsoft has no access to the data that
a customer has in the cloud we can't
look at it we don't have access to that
so for anybody that's using our asher
can layer on top of any sort of
encryption they want in addition to the
fact that we have no access it is really
a contract between you know the user
with the cell phone using their thing or
anybody that does that so you have to
you know it's essentially a buyer beware
in that sense we we will provide
whatever protection our customers want
but
I agree I quite the comment was it is
the and this is I think a very important
point what do people do it's the as you
said the shadow of the data that the
history of your actions in the cloud
that's right and and you know that's
something where we're happy to help
protect people with can I ask a really
naive question this is piggybacking off
of the gentleman's comment there about
the if I'm understanding correctly about
the the privacy and the profiling
concerns in academic research I spent a
lot of time working on science metrics
and I know that it actually in trying to
push for better transparency for
academic research unless it's dealing
with something where there are
legitimate privacy concerns such as
clinical research or something that's
under HIPAA that it actually would be
better for academic research to be able
to know what sort of actions people and
how people have been engaging with data
so I'm just I was wondering if you could
elaborate a little bit more on what your
your fear and your concern is or if it
is just fear or I'm just
misunderstanding this is a good
discussion you know sorry I didn't find
out where the question came from okay oh
okay yes sir what I'm concerned about is
that if I do any research on data that
and when i do that local then I then I
can be sure that everything happens on
this data is controlled by the local
situation when I put this research into
a cloud then it can be analyzed what
happened as I said the shadow of the
data so it's it's not what's inside of
the data but it's how the data has been
managed words what it is I want to
decide when I go public and I don't want
to be public from the beginning of my
work
no it's just just the first stage that I
want to make up my mind and once I made
up my mind I want to have the decision
what is going to happen I I just wanted
to add the the public clouds in
particular they want to make money and
if this ever happens that customers data
was disclosed it would become very
public very quickly and they would lose
a tremendous number of customers that's
not to say it won't happen but there are
significant business ramifications if
something like that happens and so I
would like to naively believe they put a
sufficient amount of protection and
attention to this issue which is why we
were not made sure our cloud was HIPAA
compliant and that you know and so in
terms of our security of the facilities
I can't even person I work for Microsoft
I can't get into those data centers
myself that security so high but but I
think the point that it was really
interesting i think was about the
difference between scientific data
provenance and computational providence
and that making that available so when
you do go public with your research to
be able to also say here's how i came to
this conclusion here are the steps in my
scientific process here was the maybe
even the blind alleys i went down here
is how i got to my result and that is
part of the scientific process and I
think exposing that is very very
important but as you say not before you
want to do it I mean it should be
completely private and you know and and
and will help you protect that
I actually have a question for the the
first speaker you mentioned this this
concept of scientists as service
providers where are these scientists are
willing to actually be service providers
well I think we've got one here who's
been doing that sort of thing I think
there may be others in the audience that
are doing that sort of thing I think I
suppose from the point of view that HMS
research is one of the research they
don't actually want to sit there and
actually run a long-term service and
there's a different mentality around
doing that around actually making sure
that serves as a stable and that sort of
stuff i mean organizations run services
researchers and research groups don't
tend to run long term services they use
the cloud and one of major advantages of
the cloud is that you can actually do
short short term things fairly
efficiently I also question the concept
of actually having large data
collections in the cloud one of the
problems we've got down under is the
fact that the transfer rates I've
actually moving a petabyte later
petabyte of data into the cloud just
make it impossible it's just it's just
the cost of just do I ya know I
certainly agree the problem in Australia
you know we need to have clouds down
there so that's a great thing here one
is being built that's durable but in
terms of communities running services I
think you can find really some there's
some very good examples in the social
sciences the data curation service at
the University of Michigan has run for
50 years as a service for the social
science research community you have also
within the life sciences I think we'll
start to see services emerge the point
is if you have something that is
valuable enough as a service that it can
be self-sustaining by a community and
and even employ people at some point to
maintain it then you have something
that's truly valuable if I agree an
individual researcher doesn't want to
devote their life to maintaining a
certain although there are people to do
that and by and large it's not a large
number they're heroes so so I think
there are a number of services that are
there out there people of quit and I
think the the men gap at the moment is
business models to sustain the
services so the real problem that we
have is that typically what happens we
create something for a one project or
set of projects and then when the
project ends then the entropy tix takes
over in the software deteriorates and
something which might have had many
staff years of effort it going into it
could which could be widely used
deteriorates now the hope of the cloud
is that well it's got you could got a
nice model for the utilization of vital
resources because you don't need to pair
you don't need to get capital to
replenish your servers it's to keep it
going but it's the software that's
sitting on that and the whatever you
have to pass on to thee to the cloud
infrastructure providers and I think
that's something that's not really clear
from here that scientists aren't
prepared to pay for anything i lo as was
pointed out by Ian Foster honest talk
earlier look pay for matlab but they all
of them seem to do that and i'll pay for
office with excel which a lot of them a
lot of them use but i don't think we've
found a good business model yet for
these services which are now cropping up
which will allow them to be sustained
over the years in the decades which they
really need to do yeah so I'm new to
hung from the software sustainability in
shoot in the UK and you almost took the
you know my entire question there I
think just following on from that we're
seeing that a lot of people as you say
Paul are willing to pay for these
services but we don't quite know what
the model is to give recognition or
reward or make people have the rights
business models to provide these
services is interesting that Dennis put
up the slide on things like ipython
notebook I think these are sort of
things you see galaxy for instance being
available in cloud services and so on
but my questions for the panel are
really the first of all is if if we do
manage to get an ecosystem of these kind
of services being provided how can we
tell which ones are the best ones for
the community to pick up and then the
second question following on for that is
how do we ensure that all of the people
who just now are just looking for tools
the people who really just want to run
matlab in the cloud and so on how
do we make sure that these people can
get to the stage of knowing how to pick
up something like galaxy in the cloud
and so on so so so I think that's that's
quite interesting because in in other
sorts of cloud services then we've got
the idea of recommendations and people
will click to like things and so on and
at the moment we don't really have that
for these sorts of cloud services except
in particular instances like my
experiment for example where you can get
information about which workflows people
are people are actually using but it'd
be interesting to see whether they sort
of social networking concepts that we've
we've seen in other areas will start to
be applied to sign so when a new let's
say we've got a framework where people
can release services in the cloud
whether they'll be ways that you can
look at the provenance and you can see
how it was how this was created you can
look to see who's using it you can look
to see people's opinions on it but we're
not yeah that'd be interesting to see
where that actually comes to pass one
small comment one other way of doing
this of understanding and evaluating
different tools in the cloud is I see
through competitions the cloud actually
could be a pretty good platform where
you have if you have a data collection
at for example there's a project going
on to do comparison of machine learning
techniques based on a standard set of
collections in the cloud where you
upload different machine learning models
and you see which one's work and it's a
way of promoting high quality
interesting new applications but it's
the same with with open-source software
how do you know which is the best stuff
it's a really important problem yeah so
my question maybe a little bit vague but
i find the cloud hard to use for high
performance computing that is in terms
of the other things that people are
talking about
it's great you know I use SkyDrive all
my stuff's out there if you know if my
laptop died right now I'd lose nothing
in terms of work so so that kind of
small scale computing which you know
that maybe the long tail the cloud is
wonderful but it turns out that when
you're trying to do high performance
computing for example there's a big
difference between a bunch of separate
machines vs big machines with shared
memory and for example and and that
seems to be hard to specify when you're
doing a cloud computing and you can I
ran into an example where my laptop with
four processors was faster than what I
was right so the so I guess it relates
to just the previous comment it it's
hard to find people that can work
through this it I finding it hard to
teach myself how to do it and to me that
if I you know if I look at this chart
i'm i'm over at that right hand column
that you know i like the cloud i don't
care about data privacy i would i'd love
to take some of the money i currently
spend managing our own systems and you
know pay somebody else to do it but I I
have trouble doing it is what I'm
running into all right I happened to I
watched Jeff work and I've seen the
challenges he's had and I've actually
seen the example that he talks about
where his laptop was much faster than a
sure to get some computation tonight I
agree I think we've got a long ways to
go one of the reasons that you know we
started to put an HP see cluster inside
the cloud that Amazon
is that is people are coming and saying
this is not enough question I get very
often is wait a minute I need something
with big memory really big memory and
that's that's important we've got 11
final well I'm you know I have the owner
I'm my name is Yogi Bear from the Center
for Earth System science at a ching hai
University I guess my question is
regarding utilizing the public cloud
platform for the data storage and access
we have been educated continually
educated that you know putting a big
data on the cloud and then we do not
need to worry about the local you know
hardware's and the IT support but on the
other hand that we need to pay for the
data storage as well as for that access
so I'm wondering is there any you know
comprehensive realistic a use case
driven study to show that the economic
advantage of utilizing public cloud for
big data storing data and access thank
you yeah that there have been many
studies and on this subject and of
course a little bit difficult because
often we we compare you know a pair with
apples because it's very difficult to
calculate particularly in in in a
research environment the full cost of
providing services I am I in my short
talk i mentioned that offensive system
are staffed by a PhD student or so so if
you compare and you know there is a
comprehensive study was done a couple of
years ago I think Stephen you I've seen
Stephen your house down there by the
yeah yeah by the EG IP polo EG on the
comparative for sir no sir no comparing
the cost of storing the data on
okay so so you can you can get the link
to their study from Steve but in general
think is not easy to do because while
the cloud and are commercially provided
so you really expose the entire cost
when you start to compare that with the
service provide to you by the local I
performance computer center others often
you hear the statement also service are
free well actually they are not free for
the taxpayer they cost a lot of money
but it's difficult to expose the entire
cost okay I think it's great question to
end on so I think we've certainly
discussed all of these these aspects and
I was a bit afraid earlier on that we
wouldn't have enough questions we've
actually had too many so so so thank you
very much to all the panel speakers and
to you for your great questions